Transcriber: Fatma Turan Aygoren
Gözden geçirme: Betül Tanrıkulu
Hiç derdi olmayan biri var mıdır acaba?
En gözümüzde büyüttüğümüz
kişileri düşünelim:
En ünlü sanatçıları,
en zengin iş adamlarını,
en iyi sporcuları.
Eminim herkesin, hepimizin
binbir türlü derdi var.
Gözümüzde büyüttüğümüz, korktuğumuz,
bir kısmı da gerçekten korkmamız gereken,
ve kontrolümüzde olmayan.
Bir an için bütün bu korkularımızın,
endişelerimizin ortadan kaybolduğunu
düşünelim.
"Şimdi artık istediğinizi yapabilirsiniz."
demeyeceğim;
çünkü başarıya ve güzelliğe giden yol,
zorlu, dertli ve acılı bir süreç.
Size sadece şunu soracağım:
Acaba derdinizi kendiniz
belirleyebilseniz,
kendiniz için neyi dert edinirdiniz?
Bu soruyu ilk olarak 12 sene önce sordum.
İyi bir işim varken, kendi
işimi yapma isteğiyle,
kurumsal hayattan ayrıldım.
İlk olarak Londra merkezli
bir startup'a katıldım.
"Aileler için Facebook" sloganıyla,
soy ağacını dijitale taşıyan
bir iş yapıyorduk.
Kısa zamanda başarılı oldu ve
yabancı bir firmaya satıldı.
Ardından yeni bir işe giriştik.
Bu sefer internet üstünden
çiçek satacaktık.
Ancak acemi girişimcilerin yaptığı birçok
hatayı biz de yaptık.
İş bölümü, ortaklık, vizyon gibi
konuları yönetemedik.
Yenilikçi bir iş yapmak istiyorduk,
ancak işe geleneksel yaklaşıyorduk.
Sonra bir başka işe daha giriştik.
Bu sefer zamanın çok ilerisinde bir işti,
ve yaptığımız işi her gören, herkes
bize uzaydan gelmişiz gibi bakıyordu.
Microsoft ile partner olduk.
Turkcell'in açtığı ihaleyi kazandık.
Mobil barkodlarla pazarlama alanında
devrim yaratacaktık.
"Her şey iyi gidecek."
derken,
iki şirket de bu işten para kazanamadı.
Almanlar yenilince
biz de yenilmiş sayıldık.
Zamanı gelmemiş bir işi kovalıyorduk,
ve benim de nefesim tükenmişti.
Kendimi kötü hissediyordum,
ne yapacağımı bilmiyordum.
Bütün birikimlerimi tüketmiştim.
Tekrardan kurumsal hayata dönebilirdim,
veya başka bir startup'a katılabilirdim.
Bu noktada size bahsettiğim
güçlü soru ile tekrar karşılaştım,
ve şu soruyu sordum:
"Hayat boyu yetecek para ve imkanım olsa,
kendimi ne iş yapmaya adarım?"
Ya da bir başka deyişle:
"Neyi dert edinirim?"
Bu noktaya geldiğimde,
aslında sevdiğim, keyif aldığım,
ve yapabileceğim bir iş yapmam
gerektiğini düşündüm.
Okumak ve öğrenmek beni her zaman
çok heyecanlandırmıştır.
Hatta, öyle ki ilkokuldayken,
sürekli müşterisi olduğum kitapçıya
bir gün gittiğimde
"Artık sana verecek kitabım kalmadı."
demişti.
Ben de benzer şekilde,
öğrenmeye ve gelişmeye açık insanlarla
bir arada olarak,
fikir üretmeyi, tartışmayı ve
bakış açımı genişletmeyi seviyorum.
"Böyle bir ortamda olmak iyi olurdu."
diye düşündüm,
ve üniversite ortamında olmayı
hayal ettim.
"Burada kendime,
öğrencilerin bakış açısına
anlamlı derecede katkıda bulunmak
ve akademik bilgi üretimine
katkıda bulunmak
iyi olurdu."
diye düşündüm.
Ancak bu sefer de
benim kaygılarım devreye girdi.
Maddi belirsizlikler,
doktora sürecindeki akademik hayattaki
belirsizlikler
gözümde oldukça büyüdü.
Ve sonra şunu düşündüm:
"Gerçekten de üniversitede
öğretim üyesi olmak için,
önce belli bir birikim sahibi olup
50 yaşıma, 60 yaşıma gelmeyi mi
beklemeliyim?"
"Bunu bugün yapmama engel var mı?"
diye düşündüm,
ve aslında bugün hiçbir engelin
olmadığını gördüm.
Benim sorun olarak gördüğüm şey,
gerçek olmayan bir varsayımdan ibaretti.
O gün CEO'luktan öğrenciliğe
ve asistanlığa terfi ettim.
Artık akademik hayatın içindeydim.
Öte yandan birçok kişinin de
şu sorusu ile karşılaştım,
hala da karşılaşıyorum:
"Peki para kazanıyor musun?"
Ben de şu cevabı veriyorum:
Akademisyenlik
para kazanmak için yapılmaz.
Ama akademisyenler para kazanıyor,
tıpkı resim ya da müzik yapan
bir sanatçı gibi.
Hatta günümüzde öyle bir hal aldı ki,
en anlamsız, en saçma, en garip
işleri yapanlar bile,
bir süre sonra bu yaptıkları işlerden
bir fayda sağlayabiliyorlar.
Mesela,
zamanının büyük bölümünü
bilgisayar oyunu oynamakla geçiren biri,
bunu bir uzmanlığa veya
bir YouTube kanalına çevirebiliyor.
Girişimcilik de aynen böyle.
Girişimcilik para kazanmak için yapılmaz.
Ama girişimciler para kazanıyor.
Peki yaptığımız işler para kazanmak için
yapılmazsa, niçin yapılır?
Çalışmanın amacı
para kazanmak değil midir?
Şirketimizi ilk kurduğumuzda,
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
Bilgisayar Mühendisliği'nde
yüksek lisans yapan bir öğrenci
çalışmak için başvurmuştu.
Ardından 5.000 TL maaş aldığı
işini bırakıp
2.000 TL maaşla bizde çalışmaya başladı.
Neden böyle yaptığını sorduğumda,
yaptığımız işin kendisini çok
heyecanlandırdığını,
ve bu işin bir parçası olmak
istediğini söyledi.
O zaman biz bile,
paradan daha güçlü,
motive edici bir iş yaptığımızın
farkında değildik.
Sonrasında anladım ki,
yeni nesil startup girişimleri
para kazanmak için çalışmıyorlar.
Daha büyük bir amaçları var.
Bu amaç, kimsenin sormaya ve çözmeye
cesaret edemeyeceği
büyük ve tek bir soruna odaklanmak
ve bunu başarma iradesini
ortaya koymak oluyor.
Mesela NASA'nın
çözemeyeceğine inandığı için
uğraşmaktan korktuğu bir sorunu
kendine dert edinen
ve uzaya giden roketleri dünyaya geri
getirmeye uğraşan Elon Musk gibi.
Dolayısıyla,
yeni nesil startup girişimleri
mevcut düzeni sorgulayan,
yerinden sarsan,
ve dünyayı değiştiren
yeni çıkış yolları yaratan
bir meydan okuma içindeler.
Ben de aslında kendimi bildim bileli
hayata karşı hep bir böyle
sınırlarımı aşmak isteyen
bir yapı içinde oldum.
Kendi işimi yapma güdüsü
her zaman içimde vardı.
Bununla beraber farkettim ki
girişimcilik şirket kurmak
ile ilgili bir konu değil.
Girişimcilik bir hayata bakış şekli.
Dolayısıyla ben de kendimi akademisyen
girişimci olarak ifade ediyorum.
Siz de ne iş yapıyor olursanız olun,
kendinizi girişimci olarak ifade edebilir
ve hayata bu pencereden bakabilirsiniz.
Bu bakışla da, yaklaşık 2 yıldır
Bloomberg HT kanalında
"Girişimcilik Dünyası"
isimli programı yapıyorum.
Burada dert edindiğim konu
girişimci denince anlaşılan
geleneksel iş adamı imajı yerine
yeni nesil startup girişimciliğini
daha geniş kesimlere tanıtabilmek.
Bir girişimci, akademisyen
ve televizyoncu olarak
şunu anlamaya çalışıyorum:
Yeni nesil startup girişimlerinin
geleneksel şirketlerden ne farkı var?
Ve bu yeni girişimcilik tipinden
ne öğrenebiliriz?
"Bu neden önemli?" derseniz;
dünya eskisine göre çok daha karmaşık,
belirsiz ve öngörülemeyen bir hal aldı,
ve bu dünyada en iyi
ilerlemeyi becerenler
bu yeni nesil startup girişimleri.
Şimdi size iki örnek vermek istiyorum.
Birincisi; teknoloji girişimciliği
denilince akla gelen ilk isim olan
Yemek Sepeti'nin kurucularından
Nevzat Aydın.
Diğeri de geçtiğimiz yıl en başarılı
girişimci seçilen Nusret.
İkisi de girişimci, ikisi de başarılı,
ancak ikisinin de yaklaşımları
ve hayata bakışları çok farklı.
Öncelikle en temel fark;
yeni nesil iş yapanların
arayış içinde olmaları.
Öte yandan,
geleneksel iş yapanların da
mevcut bilinen bir işin
uygulayıcısı olmaları.
Yemeksepeti ilk ortaya çıktığında,
2001 yılında işin kendisi belirsizdi.
Kurucular bir fikre sahipti,
ne yapacaklarını biliyorlardı,
ama bunu nasıl yapacaklarını
bilmiyorlardı.
"Restaurantlarla iletişim nasıl olmalı?",
"İnsanlar nasıl sipariş vermeli?",
"Teslimat nasıl olmalı?"
gibi konuların hepsi
keşfedilmeyi bekliyordu.
Bunun için,
birçok deneme yanılma yapmaları,
hata yapmaları ve öğrenmeleri gerekti.
Öte yandan, Nusret
bilinen bir işi,
restaurant işini,
herkesten daha iyi ve farklı bir şekilde
hayata geçirmeyi amaç edindi.
Burada yaptığı iş; bilinen bir işin
iyi bir uygulayıcısı olmasıydı.
Dolayısıyla,
yeni nesil işler keşif yaparken,
bilinen işleri yapanlar fetih yapıyorlar.
Fetih için, büyük kaynaklara sahip olmak
ve bir savaşa hazırlanmak gerekiyor.
Öte yandan keşif ise,
bırakın savaşmayı;
geniş katılımlı bir desteği
ve iş birliğini gerektiriyor.
Çünkü, belirsizliklerle ancak
bu şekilde mücadele edebilirsiniz.
"İkisi de girişimci, ikisi de başarılı."
dedik.
İkisinin yaptığı işe,
bir de risk ve belirsizlik ekseninden
bakarsak şunu söyleyebilirim:
Nusret bilinen bir işi yaparak,
yatırım yapıyor.
Yani risk alıyor.
Ancak,
bilinen bir işi yaptığı için de
belirsizliği düşük bir iş yapıyor.
Öte yandan, Nevzat'ın yaptığı
işin belirsizliği çok yüksek;
çünkü bilinmeyen bir iş yapıyor.
Ancak başlangıçta çok yatırım
gerekmediği için
aldığı risk oldukça düşük.
Kendi fırsat maliyeti veya
zaman maliyeti dışında
bir finansal risk altına girmiyor.
Şimdi burası enteresan bir konu;
çünkü girişimcilik genelde
macera, risk ve cesaret konularıyla,
kavramlarıyla özdeşleştirilir.
Ancak,
yeni nesil startup girişimcileri,
başarılı girişimciler
risk almayı sevmiyorlar.
Risklerini en aza indirerek
belirsizliklerle mücadele ediyorlar.
Belirli dünyada, bilinen dünyada
iş yapmak istiyorsanız da
riskinizi en aza indirerek
iş yapabilirsiniz.
Bunun da örneği var;
seyyar satıcılıktan restaurant
haline gelen Midyeci Ahmet gibi.
Öte yandan Ar-Ge ve teknoloji alanında
iş yapıyorsanız,
vereceğim örnek:
Osman Kibar.
Tanımayanlar için söyleyelim,
kendisi yaşlanmayı tersine çeviren
bir biyoteknoloji üzerine çalışıyor.
Şirketinin değeri,
tam 12 milyar dolar.
Amerika'da kurduğu şirketinin şu anda
piyasaya sunduğu bir ürün yok.
Buna rağmen şirketinin
%4'ünden daha azı karşılığında
438 milyon dolar yatırım almış durumda.
"Hiç para kazanmayan şirket olur mu?"
demiştik.
Eğer belirsizliği yüksek
bir iş yapıyorsanız,
arayış halindeyseniz
ve keşif içindeyseniz,
para için çalışmıyorsunuz.
Daha büyük bir amaç var,
bir derdiniz var,
ve bu derdinizi
çözmek için çalışıyorsunuz.
Öte yandan, Türkiye'de yaşadığımız
gerçeğini de göz ardı etmek istemiyorum.
Çünkü bu da bizim üzerimizde
ekstra bir risk faktörü
barındırdığımız anlamına geliyor.
Bu sebeple sadece şunu söylemek istiyorum:
Üzerimize daha fazla
risk almaya gerek yok.
Eğer bir yatırım yapmaya karar verirseniz
veya girişimci olmaya karar verirseniz,
riskinizi en aza indirerek,
belirsizliklerle mücadele
etmeniz gerekiyor.
Bunu en iyi becerenler de
Google, Apple, Facebook, Amazon
ya da YemekSepeti gibi
yeni nesil startup şirketleri.
Bu şirketler para kazanmak
amacıyla yola çıkmadılar;
bir dertleri vardı,
yapılamaz denileni yaptılar,
ve sonra da dünyanın en çok kazanan
şirketleri oldular.
Dolayısıyla,
biz de hayata bakışımıza
ve yapmak istediğimiz
işleri gerçekleştirirken
bu yeni nesil startup şirketlerinden
çok şey öğrenebiliriz.
Bunları sizin için üç maddede topladım.
Birincisi; bu şirketler bilmeye değil
öğrenmeye odaklanıyorlar.
Bilinen dünya; geleneksel işler,
uzmanlık ve bilgi üzerine kurulu.
Öte taraftan bilinmeyen işler,
belirsizlik dünyasındaki işler,
yaratıcılık ve öğrenmeye dayalı.
Bilinen dünyada biz işleri
daha verimli yapmaya çalışıyoruz.
%10, %20,%30 daha iyi
daha ucuz, daha karlı olmaya çalışıyoruz
ve bunu da uzmanına soruyoruz.
Öte yandan bilinmeyenler dünyasında
bu şirketler 10 kat, 20 kat, 30 kat
daha iyi olmaya çalışıyorlar,
ama bunun cevabını verebilecek
olan bir uzman yok.
Dolayısıyla bu dünyada uzman olan kişiler
yaratıcı fikirlere çekimser yaklaşıyorlar.
Birçok araştırma bunu gösteriyor.
İnsanlar değişim istiyorlar
ancak kimse değişmek istemiyor.
Bu dünyada öne çıkan,
belirsizliklerle mücadele etmek için
sahip olmamız gereken en önemli şey;
hızlı öğrenme becerisi edinmek
ve bunu en iyi becerenler de
yeni nesil startup şirketleri.
İkincisi; bu şirketler hayal ediyorlar,
merak ediyorlar, dert ediniyorlar.
Eskiden dünya öyle bir haldeydi ki
çok büyük hayallerimiz vardı,
ancak teknoloji hayallerimizin
hızına yetişemiyordu.
Şimdi dünya tersine döndü
teknolojiyle neler yapabileceğimizi
hayal bile edemiyoruz.
Teknoloji artık bu seviyeye geldi.
Bu dünya dolayısıyla hem bilim adamı gibi
hem sanatçı gibi düşünmeyi gerektiriyor.
İş dünyası, iş adamı bakışı rasyoneldir.
Bu dünyada yapılabilirlik önemlidir.
Belirsizlikler ve riskler korkutucudur.
Öte yandan yeni nesil startup şirketleri;
Picasso gibi, Mozart gibi, Einstein gibi.
Apple Kurucusu Steve Jobs da
bunun en güzel örneği.
Gerçek bir sanatçı,
eserini kaça satacağını
düşünerek yapmaz.
O içinden gelen katlanılmaz duyguyu
yaratıcı bir esere
dönüştürmek için uğraşır.
Yapılması gerekeni yapar,
söylenmesi gerekeni söyler,
görülmesi gerekeni görür.
Günün sonunda yaptığı iş
hiç para etmeyebilir
veya dünyanın en önemli şaheseri olabilir.
Ancak bunu ortaya koymazsa
bunu görme şansı hiçbir zaman olmayacak.
Öte yandan geleneksel dünyanın bekçileri
bu yaratıcılıktan korkar.
Tıpkı, Einstein'ın patent dairesinde
memurken yazdığı makalenin
çok yaratıcı olduğu
gerekçesiyle reddedilmesi
ve Nobel bilim kurulunun yıllarca
Einstein'a ödül vermeyi reddetmesi gibi.
Ancak yaratıcı güç ortaya çıktığında bunun
önünde durmak neredeyse imkansızdır.
Üçüncüsü; bu şirketler
çok hızlı hareket ediyorlar.
Hemen harekete geçiyorlar.
Çok büyük bir hayaliniz olabilir
zaten bu hayalinize nasıl gideceğinizi
biliyor olsanız
bunun adı hayal değil;
hedef olurdu.
Hayal, nasıl gideceğinizi bilmediğiniz
bir yolda ilerlemeyi istemek demek.
Bunun için bugün atabileceğiniz
ilk adım neyse onu atın.
Büyük düşünün ama küçük başlayın.
Küçük adımlarla ve bu yolda
hızlı hareket edin.
Neredeyseniz, neye sahipseniz
onunla orada ilk adımı atın.
Her zaman atabileceğiniz
bir ilk adım vardır.
Sonra bir başka adım
ve bir başka adım daha.
Ben bu arayış ve hareket haline
"huzurlu rahatsızlık" adını veriyorum.
Sahip olmadıklarınız için yakınmak
veya sahip olmayı beklemek yerine
sahip olduklarınız için şükredin.
Huzuru burada bulacaksınız.
Öte yandan,
arayış bir rahatsızlık halidir.
Bu yolda yakıtınız da kendinize
seçtiğiniz derdiniz olacak.
Bu sayede, cesareti bulacak
ve zorluklara göğüs gerebileceksiniz.
Bütün bunları toparlarsak;
dünya eskisine göre
çok daha hızlı bir şekilde değişiyor
ve çok daha belirsiz
bir dünyada yaşıyoruz.
Risksiz gördüğümüz konfor alanlarımız
düşündüğümüz kadar güvenli olmayabilir.
Hiç hareket etmemek ve yerimizde durmak
o kadar da iyi bir çıkış yolu olmayabilir;
çünkü üzerinde durduğumuz zemin değişiyor,
altımızdan kayabilir.
"Ben sadece işimi yapıyorum."
veya "Ben sadece bir çalışanım."
diye düşünmeyin.
Çünkü yaptığınız işler
veya çalıştığınız kurumların geleceği
belirsiz olabilir.
Dolayısıyla ben şunu savunuyorum:
Girişimciliği bir kafa yapısı
olarak öğrenmeli
ve hepimiz hayatta kalmak için
bir araç olarak görmeliyiz.
Bunun için,
sürekli öğrenmeye odaklanmalı,
hayal etmeli, merak etmeli
ve dert edinmeliyiz.
Ardından da hemen harekete geçmeliyiz.
Belki de sonra bunu paraya
ve etkiye çevirebiliriz.
Yeni nesil startup girişimlerinden
bu konuda çok şey öğrenebiliriz.
Teşekkürler.